America will never be a socialist
country declared President Trump to an
upper applause from everyone except one
person Bernie Sanders while it seems
laughable at the time Bernie Sanders is
not alone as democratic socialism is
gaining steam across the u.s. what used
to be found upon us become very popular
especially among young people a
socialist society is one in which the
workers collectively owned the means of
production instead of production being
in the hands of a few private
individuals ideally it is supposed to be
a worker's paradise I think we would all
agree that pure socialism will never
work due to corruption and the natural
inequality between people as history has
shown us again and again the USSR in
East Germany to Cuba but democratic
socialism is different democratic
socialism is a way of organizing society
in which all people are guaranteed a
decent and dignified life by D
commodifying basic human needs basically
is altering government regulations and
taxes in order to offer free health care
tuition free college and promote a green
environment as this has arguably proved
very fruitful in countries like Norway
Sweden Denmark and Finland so what if
the u.s. adopted democratic socialism
today now before you guys are up in the
comments down below let's take a calm
civilised look at this first of all to
fund all those ventures
income tax has to go up not just for the
rich but for everyone if you take a look
at those northern European countries
they all have sky-high income taxes
Finland ranges from 49% to 62% Denmark
range from 55 to 66% and Sweden range
from 51 to 62% this means that if you
make an average salary would have to pay
over half her income in income tax alone
couple that with state tax sales tax and
property tax and you'd easily be paying
more than two-thirds of your total
income to the government and to make
matters even worse these higher income
tax rates won't affect the rich or any
corporations at all companies like Apple
Amazon and Google have tens of thousands
of accountants and financial advisers in
order to make the best possible choices
these people are literally hired to go
to work every single day and figure out
how these companies can best manage
their money as a result these companies
are able to find the best way
right off most of their profits and
considering this even if you made the
tax rate 100% it really wouldn't matter
to them
just take a look at this we all know
Amazon is one of the best at avoiding
paying taxes legally there have been
years where they have literally paid
nothing in taxes despite being one of
the biggest companies in the world in
2016 they only paid a miniscule 1.4
billion dollars in taxes asked for Apple
the biggest company in the world whose
can't sleep over a thousand dollar
monitor stands with the 285 point 1
billion dollars in cash reserves alone
only paid fifteen point seven billion
dollars in 2016
clearly increasing tax rate or to new
regulations will not get these companies
to pay more taxes they will always have
waste avoid paying taxes or at least
less taxes than the general public and
if you were somehow able to get them to
pay more taxes they are simply going to
cut jobs hurting thousands of employees
this same thing goes for anyone making
over $1,000,000 per year if you guys are
interested in how exactly these people
avoid paying taxes consider checking out
a video from one of my favorite creators
Graham Stefan who breaks down how much
he pays in taxes after making two
million dollars per year spoiler is
probably less than you not just
percentage-wise but money wise as well
as a result
Congresswoman AOC suggests a 70% tax for
people earning over 10 million dollars a
year
won't actually be very effective in fact
the Tax Foundation estimates that adding
a new 70 percent tax bracket would only
bring in an additional two hundred
ninety-one billion dollars over ten
years so most of the funding for that 10
year 42 trillion dollar budget will come
from ordinary Americans working
white-collar jobs but what about all the
benefits from democratic socialism well
most of the budget would be going
towards universal health care so let's
start with that the benefits are obvious
everyone can get the care they need when
they need it without having to worry
about the cost plus it lowers the cost
of health care as a whole as the
government will be able to leverage the
size of the medical market to negotiate
better pricing but here's the thing
saying that would be unfair is a
significant understatement 5 percent the
u.s. population consumed 50 percent
health care costs while the health is
50% of the population only consumed 3%
this means the healthy and wealthy are
asked to care for those who are poor and
sick now I'm
that most wealthy people be more than
happy to help out a family with the
child who is born Daquan disease or a
health-conscious father who needs heart
surgery due to genetic predisposition
but that is only a handful of people it
is simply not fair to push the burden of
paying for health care on to the rich
when it is an individual who chooses to
smoke for 40 years
or chooses to eat unhealthy leading to
obesity not only that but by providing
universal free health care Americans
will be less conscious about their
health in general and Americans will
start making unnecessary visits to the
hospital so whether you like it or not
if you're a healthy middle-class
American you're going to have to pay for
the health care of people who have
chosen an unhealthy lifestyle moving on
to the next most expensive thing in the
budget the federal job guarantee today
in the US it's not jobs that we need as
we have plenty of jobs in fact since
June of 2018 there have been more jobs
available than unemployed people an
unemployment rate is at an all-time low
now I'm not here to argue that this is
because of Trump or Obama or Kim jong-un
or whoever else but rather show that
there are plenty of opportunities
available so most people who want the
job can get a job of the people who are
unemployed you have to remember that
most of people are people simply
switching jobs or may have been laid off
but can't quickly get another job only
nineteen point two percent of the three
point seven percent who are unemployed
have been unemployed for over twenty
seven weeks now there are definitely
hardworking people in this category but
there are also people who are unemployed
for other reasons like consistently
coming late to work or having a bad
attitude in general plus with the
federal job guarantee people working
minimum wage will be less motivated to
keep their jobs and perform at their
best especially if the federal job pays
better so if there was a federal job
guarantee we would see a lot of people
willing to work minimum wage jobs
forcing companies to increase minimum
wage now while that sounds good
companies can't just increase the wage
even if they wanted to as their profit
margins are usually quite maker
especially in the food industry as a
result companies will end up forcing
more work onto fewer employees and
increasing the price of their products
they sell this ends up making workers
lives more miserable while also
increasing costs for customers the
perfect example is Amazon from your
perspective you may see Amazon's
the most bad companies in the world with
his founder being the richest man alive
but in reality they don't have much
money at all while they had 232 billion
dollars in sales last year they actually
lost 2.1 billion dollars on
international sales and only made 7.2
billion dollars and domestic sales
meaning their profit margins only around
2% for amazon.com I think you understand
why they can't just double them in a way
from 7.2 to $5 to 15 without any other
changes anyways finally we have tuition
free college first let's take a look at
the benefits tuition free college will
help decrease crippling student debt and
on allow students pursue any education
they want without the worry of cost but
this doesn't actually solve the entire
problem or even most of it tuition only
accounts for thirty nine point five
percent of total average college costs
students will still have to pay for
housing books supplies transportation to
other fees so students was to have large
debts which is perfectly outlined by
countries that already have tuition free
college for instance in 2013 and Sweden
where tuition is free the average - in
debt was $19,000 that same year the
average - in debt in the u.s. was quite
comparable at twenty four thousand eight
hundred dollars so free tuition doesn't
necessarily mean free degree and not to
mention that when you're getting
something for free you don't value it as
much completion rates for college will
no doubt drop in students well on
average how worst grades while student
debt is often burdensome the mounting
student debt definitely motivates many
students to get good grades finished
college and get a job at hard to pay it
off they have often invested too much
money to back out but when tuition is
free if you're living at home you invest
a very small and money into the degree
and are much more likely to not see it
through if you guys haven't sensed a
theme yet the u.s. adopting Democratic
socially would simply encourage
carelessness if the government is
providing free health care tuition free
College I'm backing the public with a
federal job guarantee this is all just
asking her people to be more careless
see before people will be taking better
care of their health and setting aside
money for medical emergencies people
will be accountable for starting a
college education and taking on student
loan debt people will be working harder
at their jobs to keep them but with
these new programs people will be less
health
conscious people would be less inclined
to finish college and people will be
less inclined to work hard at their jobs
and they'll be less responsible with
their money and for the u.s. this is
terrible as most people in the US don't
have an income problem at all
they have a spending problem the average
household income in the US is 86
thousand dollars with 30% of households
bring in six figures this means that
even if a husband and wife only worked
for 30 years they would be earning over
two point five million dollars
first of all student loan debt only
takes up 1.5%
so student loan debt is definitely
manageable but what is even more
surprising is that somehow the average
American only has one hundred and
seventy two thousand dollars saved at
retirement less than seven percent and
that's not even considering any raises
or promotions or the fact that the
average American works for more than 30
years if the government is taking care
of all major responsibilities from
health care and college to retirement
this is only going to escalate this
already growing issue instead of fixing
it and as for the American dream if you
go to college for a useful degree and
get a job while managing your finances
well I assure you that you will be able
to make a nice income have a nice family
and house and have plenty of money for
retirement which is the American dream
where you face problems like corporate
culture absolutely but can you overcome
them without the government of course
and are there people that work hard but
can't get a job being health conscious
by facing large medical bills wanting to
pursue education but finances are
stopping them yes but only a very small
portion of this population actually has
no control over the situation the rest
are simply making poor financial
decisions and life choices and
government aid will only lead to them
making more unwise choices thus
introducing government involvement and
taxing eighty-two percent of people who
have already achieved or are on their
way to achieve the American Dream is
just not the right answer as well we'll
help a handful of people who deserve it
it will also unnecessarily help millions
of people who just need to handle their
money better on the backs of people who
made the right choices the first time
around but that's just what I think what
do you guys think how do you guys feel
about the u.s. adopting democratic
socialism makes a comment that down
below
also if you guys like this video too
messed up a like and consider
subscribing if I see more videos just
like this one but until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one
you